vous connaissez tous l'Homme de Vitruve
se célèbre dessin de Léonard de Vinci
vous en retrouverez d'autres au Clos
Lucé le célèbre château ancienne
résidence du peintre et scientifique
italien exposent 50 de ses croquis
représentant diverses parties du corps
humain de manière très précise pour
l'époque preuve d'un homme très en
avance sur son temps et qui a été le
premier à représenter parfaitement la
colonne vertébrale reportage de Léa
Turquie
[Musique]
corps humain vu par Léonard de Vinci
maquette vidéo est reproduction à
l'identique de ses croquis le peintre
ingénieur architecte est aussi chercheur
à la croisée des mondes entre l'art et
l'anatoma donc on peut considérer que au
travers de son approche scientifique on
a un dessin très artistique ça sa
manière de dessiner absolument
remarquable et inédite nous montre qu'il
avait une fibre artistique absolument
exceptionnelle
un coup de crayon hors du commun pour
mieux comprendre le corps humain 30 ans
de travaux que Leonardo Vinci n'a jamais
réussi à publier de la scène en passant
par l'Homme de Vitruve jusqu'à la
reproduction de sa propre salle de
dissection avec un réalisme à faire
froid dans le dos une façon aussi de
lutter contre certaines idées reçues
l'idée que Léonard aurait dit fécqué
pour apprendre à peindre c'est
absolument faux quand on regarde la
chronologie
des défunts anatomiques et des peintures
Léonard pratique la dissection comme
toujours parce qu'il cherche à percer
les secrets de l'univers et
particulièrement les secrets de l'humain
et les secrets du vivant
Léonard de Vinci et l'anatomie la
mécanique de la vie c'est à découvrir
dès maintenant au Château du Clos du CA
Amboise une nouvelle exposition éphémère
installée jusqu'au 17 septembre
[Musique]